75 basis point hike from the federal
reserve uh their entire talk track all
their talking points
a recession is not here we do not see a
recession uh we do not believe the
united states economy is in a recession
first why are they raising interest
rates at 75 basis points and being so
aggressive
if the last one didn't work
well give the guys some credit uh their
monetary policy at least according to
them and i would tend to agree with this
uh takes time to filter through the
economy um you know it doesn't impact
everyone because there's a lot of debt
that's not on floating rate basis
there's a lot of debt that's obviously
on fixed rate including most mortgages
so it takes time for you know for uh you
know incremental consumers and
incremental um sort of people who are
tapping debt markets to really feel the
impact of that so ultimately what the
policy choices that they're making today
are intended to have an impact on the
economy let's call it uh the general
consensus on this is somewhere between
two to three to four quarters down the
road
as we look at 75 basis points
50 was kind of the general thought
process a couple of months ago and they
jacked up the 75. could they go to 100
do you think 75 is kind of the upper
bound of what is possible
yeah in fact i mean it's probably the
last 75 basis point hike we're likely to
get um if you think about sort of so 100
basis points was sort of that was shot
for dad really quickly um on the other
side of that inflation report the uh we
sent out and that we the fomc sent out
bullard and walla to sort of uh tap that
down um but as it relates to um you know
the continuation of 75 basis points
we're probably going to have to see
inflation pressure continue to build
from here um now it's not necessarily
likely to continue to build particularly
on the headline side because we have
seen a a pretty significant decline in
energy and agriculture prices that
should start to feed through into
headline cpi we do however see core cbi
pressures continue to build this is
something we talked about last on the
show with the new acceleration to an
all-time high median cpi on a
three-month annualized basis sticky cpi
accelerated to 40 uh year high on
in terms of on a theoreticalized basis
as well so we are seeing a kind of a
blue push higher in core inflation but
it might be overwhelmed by declining
food and energy prices as it relates to
headline
as we begin to look at some of those
inflation measurements uh they continue
to talk about 9.1 percent uh
in a couple weeks ago you and i were
talking and you were talking about the
acceleration of kind of the three-month
uh annualized inflation do you think
that that plays into kind of their
continued aggressiveness is even though
they only talk about europe
this is a problem right like we all know
that inflation should eventually come
down on a year over your rate of change
basis just due to base effects uh we
don't need to unpack base effects here
that's probably not the right audience
but
but the problem with you know kind of
anchoring on base effects uh to get
inflation down which i think a lot of
investors are making this mistake which
is if you only rely on base effects to
get inflation down you're going to wind
up with a structurally higher kind of a
base rate based level of inflation by
the end of that process and so it's my
belief and and i think you know just
based on the kind of the tea leaves we
continue to hear out of fed over out of
fed heads and obviously out of power
yesterday is that the annualized the
momentum the sequential change in
inflation is really what's driving the
boat from a policy standpoint and the
most recent data points we're getting
you know if you look at on a three-month
annualized rate of change basis like
pretty much everything in the entire
inflation basket is accelerating to the
upside with the exception of energy so i
mean that's um that's an issue for the
fed uh is really an issue for markets
quite frankly because it means you know
that inflation is likely to continue
being a problem for longer than the sort
of you know the growth dynamics in the
in the economy uh would appreciate let's
talk about the labor market i know
you've got this chart here that shows
the labor market is too strong
for the fed to stop tightening that
seems to be one of two things they
continue to point to even though gdp
growth is negative now for two
consecutive quarters uh they say hey
employment looks strong and uh consumer
spending still looks pretty healthy
what's going on in the labor market
yeah great question man so the reason i
sent you a bunch of charts most of them
revolve around the labor market the
reason i sent those charts is because we
can unpack all of them
the fed is now shifting its sort of
focus back in the direction of its dual
mandate you know obviously it has the
price stability mandate but it also has
the maximum employment mandate so
yesterday it gave the investors sort of
um it kind of tipped its cap and nodded
to investors who are increasingly
concerned about growth and the
possibility of what we call a hashtag
actual recession which is different uh
than the technical recession that was
reported today uh so going back to the
labor market the strength of the labor
market powell effectively said very
clearly and cogently hey look the late
market is too strong for us you anyone
to be worried about recession right now
um and so this is i'm going to putting
up that chart about uh slide 82 uh from
our macro scottie report uh just shows
um you know kind of three main
indicators that i think the fed is
anchoring on to give them um to give
them confidence that the landmark is
really strong so the first uh
plot in the upper panel just shows the
ratio between total job openings and
total unemployed people and at 1.9 x uh
which is where we are today with the red
dotted line you know we're you know more
than double that you know sort of the
pre-covet trend of 0.9 which is the blue
dotted line and that chart um the middle
panel shows the private sector quits
rate so this is the percentage of people
who have jobs uh that are quitting uh in
any given month and obviously when you
quit your job it's usually to go find a
a better job or a higher paying job et
cetera like that so it's an indication
of how tight the labor market is
that number is at 3.1 percent coming off
an all-time high last fall relative and
that's much higher than the uh you know
pre-covert trend of 2.4 and then lastly
the bottom panel
we show the employment cost index which
is the broadest measure of wages of
broadest measure of you know sort of
wages in the in the economy and that
number at 4.5 percent is is effectively
a double of the 2.5 percent pre-covert
trend so when the fed looks at these
statistics it's seeing a labor market
that is way too hot to stop tightening
if they're going to um if they're
looking at growth as a sort of indicator
that they can slow down on tightening
and anchoring the that segment of growth
indicators on the labor market blade
market is not going to give them any
signals anytime soon
as you think about this labor market
how do you measure we're seeing
at least headlines
layoffs hiring freezes like i kind of
think of it as uh there's a wall and
there's cracks in the wall now
and sure the dam hasn't busted yet we're
not at you know four and a half five
percent unemployment or anything like
that
but it does feel like we're kind of
starting to see the cracks we're seeing
tick up just a little bit is that
something that you worry about or do you
think that we'll have such a uh kind of
multi-month you know uh headway
or runway to actually see
that market changing and it'll give them
enough time to kind of change their mind
because it won't happen overnight where
we just go from 3.6 to 4.5 unemployment
yeah so to be clear it could happen
overnight it's just very unlikely to
happen overnight um and the reason i say
that is that you know we have not seen a
significant enough decline in sort of
aggregate income consumer spending you
know cons
and sort of a non-residential fixed
investment business investment to really
kind of get you kind of concerned about
a jump condition lower in the total
employment and in jobs market um the
reality is going back to the headlines
we're saying we certainly are starting
to see cracks in the dam i mean you know
you can start to piece together all
these different companies telling you
that hey we're laying off i don't know
10 000 people or 10 of our workforce or
we're freezing hiring and all that
stuff's going to get worse and worse and
worse on an extended period over
extended period of time because again
the labor market is lagging with respect
to the economic cycle with respect to
the market cycle you know when you look
at the labor market and one we're going
back to some of these headlines right
you know the headlines make the news
right the headlines that would get you
to click on the article but no one's
going to put out a headline that says
company xyz is increasing hiring by 10
000 or company abc is actually
increasing his workforce by 10
but that's actually what's been
happening if you go to slide 83 that
next chart pump
where we show i think we talked about
this chart after the jobs report a few
weeks ago but it's important to sort of
reiterate for those who missed that show
which is the labor market is is
overheating by a double i mean we kind
of alluded to that in the previous chart
but this next chart uh slide 83 where we
show private payrolls growth uh that's
the first cluster of bars the light blue
bars the the pre-covert trend the fiber
trend through 2019 the dark blue bars
the most recent month june is the most
recent jobs report we have and so at 3.4
percent of private payrolls growth on a
three-month annualized basis that's
literally more than double than where we
um you know what we saw on the in the
pre-covert trend average hourly earnings
that second customer bars 5.8 percent
you know basically double uh the
pre-covert trend as well and then lastly
the last cluster of bars we show
aggregate labor income you know growing
at eight percent i mean versus a
pre-covert trend four point four percent
i mean it's telling you that you know
the media are doing a very poor job of
actually reporting the labor market um
from a balanced perspective you know the
reality is the lag market continues and
again because it's a lagging indicator
it's lagging all the growth that we had
last year it's lagging the all-time
highs we saw in january the reason those
things continue to be very robust is
because again it's a lagging indicator